ils avaient osé espérer une victoire dès
le premier tour des élections
présidentielles mais des partisans de
Kemal killingsaru ont passé une nuit
difficile maintenant je payais multiplic
et rester debout avec sa fille
et tout ça et de pleurer à cette heure
déception s'ajoutait ce matin la crainte
qui ne paie le prix de cet espoir c'est
le président erdouane désormais favori
devait emporter les élections au second
tour moi je crois que ça sera plus dur
pour nous républicain
c'est très dur ce soit près de moi j'ai
beaucoup de doutes
d'autres étaient résignés
endurci on va tenter de nouveau et
perdre de nouveau ce n'est rien on perd
depuis 20 ans
ce qui nous vaut et marquant pour les
partisans du président Erdogan c'est que
c'est la première fois que le dirigeant
devra se soumettre aux électeurs pour un
deuxième tour
que malgré sa capacité à mobiliser sa
base il ressort des derniers mois
affaiblis
si le peuple nous emmène au second tour
nous le respecterons disait-il cette
nuit avant l'annonce officielle
aujourd'hui
avec un deuxième tour qui est maintenant
confirmé les yeux se tournent vers les
5% des lecteurs qui ont plutôt choisi le
troisième candidat qui était en liste
hier sinan ohan l'ultra nationalisme
convient marchander son appui à l'un ou
l'autre des deux candidats la droite
nationaliste a performé au-delà des
attentes à la fois dans le scrutin
présidentiel et législatif qui se
déroulait aussi ce dimanche
pour endosser l'un des deux candidats la
promesse d'une expulsion immédiate des
réfugiés syriens et pour Kemal Kelly
taroudou le rejet du parti kurde qu'il
appuie actuellement
si la compétition ne s'annonce pas série
au cours des deux prochaines semaines
elle va prendre les allures d'une lutte
nationaliste
les deux camps vont chercher à prouver
qu'ils ont plus à offrir aux électeurs
nationalistes
à ce chapitre mise à part la promesse de
Kemal Kelly jaru de renvoyer les
réfugiés syriens dans leur pays d'ici 2
ans le président erdan a une bonne
longueur d'avance sur son adversaire
il nous a rendu une indépendance totale
d'y arrive qui a voté pour le Président
erdan
il parle de pommes de terre d'oignons
regardez plutôt les résultats
aujourd'hui j'ai des drones j'ai des
missiles j'ai des avions tout est
produit ici
qui est mal qu'il est pas encore
présenté à ses partisans mais c'est
peut-être à eux qu'il doit d'abord
penser en attendant un bain de foule il
a voulu sur les réseaux sociaux compris
le sentiment d'impuissance qui en habite
aujourd'hui plusieurs
je suis ici vous êtes ici leur a-t-il
dit je jure que je vais lutter jusqu'au
bout
je ne veux pas perdre espoir dit Ferial
au bord des larmes mais je ne crois pas
que notre avenir soit beau ça aurait dû
changer au moins on aurait dû avoir la
chance d'essayer mais certains décident
de s'en réfléchir ils obéissent comme
des fanatiques
dans la journée de lundi la Livre Turque
s'est effondrée se rapprochant de son
plus bas historique
ici Marie-Eve Bédard Radio-Canada
Istanbul